welcome back to the Rich Eisen show and
we're thrilled to have back here one of
my favorite guests and I'm not just
saying that because you're sitting right
here I think you oh yeah what do you
want steroids actually on steroids
Bryan Cranston last flag flying in
select theaters now I have to disqualify
this show because of your steroid use
you know what I thought about that yeah
before before taking that steroid and
butt and vacate all other shows before
it you know if there was a banner here
at the show I'd have to take it down but
my back pain was so searing now wouldn't
it be disheartening if you took the
steroid and you had the best show ever
then you go oh my god oh I have to take
more steroids how can you go off the
steroid I guess that is the conundrum
ooh that everyone thinking that it
wasn't a great show so good for you
actually it's it's been a great show so
far so unfortunately I'm gonna have to
keep this thing and keep it going yeah
keep it going
it is great to see ya since you and I
last spoke here on this show your
Dodgers went to the World Series and and
I was there for one of the games for
Game two and Vin Scully came out if you
caught any of this the pre the the first
pitch where he came out yes you don't
wanna see me I need a relief pitcher
here Fernando Valenzuela yeah here's
here was my tip I was I'm I was in
London rehearsing for a play yes and I
am like the only person in London who
cares about the World Series wearing my
Dodger hat and I had to figure out
through mlb.com how I can watch the game
in its entirety without knowing the
outcome first okay so you could you
could put on it in the settings so
there's no score there's no news and
then like and you just go on and I had a
little blockage thing here and I went
right to it and live and here goes and I
would see it from the beginning
I would never check my phone or talk to
anyone black out sports black out which
is so tough in the 21st century oh my
god you can't move you can't right go
anywhere and even in London I was afraid
of finding out the score so I just holed
up into the hotel room like a hermit
watching this bloodshot eyes and of
course then I didn't know there was that
five hour game that went in that was
insane was insane tyst
and I am proud to say I stuck around to
extra innings for that night it was
because I did see some people in this
town people that you would know people
that we have all seen on telephones at
the time when I made that comment when
somebody from Arrested Development we're
talking about right yeah so me being
from New York City I always watched the
home run that Gibson hit again oh yeas
and I would always have fun seeing with
the arc of the ball leaving the stadium
the tail lights beyond the right-field
gasps of all the people who left and I
always thought to myself there's such
fair-weathered fans in Los Angeles until
I moved out here went to a single Dodger
game and stayed all nine innings and I
would never do that again I almost
passed away due to hunger and thirst in
the car getting out of that stadium it's
so I'm totally can well because we break
the record all the time we have three
and a half million people go to games
every year so that there's a lot of
congestion and
yeah LA itself I know congestion but I
did stick around that night that was
something but what if they Bryan
Cranston you're on the Rich Eisen show
that is a very 21st century story that
you just told that in the 20th century
you would just say I didn't listen to
radio right that's you were able to not
know what the final score is right now
you're like so I had my smartphone and I
turned off the alert badges yeah I
didn't pick up my smartphone because I
was fearful that I would see a text from
someone or you know and I so I didn't I
just cut everything off and watched it
in pure agony but it was a fun season
there's a great season it was a it was a
great series and I gotta say I think the
best team actually won that one because
they they pulled it together now that
being said as a die-hard Dodger fan back
in June I was saying get Verlander this
is the best chance we have and had had
in almost 30 years
lock it down right now I even put out a
hashtag Verlander in blue
I say get him get him now and we've got
it had they gotten Justin Verlander
instead of you Darvish we'd be wearing
their rings right now I said any
argument to that the only thing I would
change is that you probably would have
been playing the Yankees and not even
the Astros play that and you you
probably would have beaten the Yankees
but you never know yeah yeah yes totally
agree cuz he made the he put the Astros
in the world's put him in he really did
yeah look at your general managing
wouldn't you love to love to be a
general manager really I think I would
leave the acting profession to head take
a shot at being a general manager of a
major league baseball team and what
would your philosophy be of being a
general manager trade him collect and
trade no I
I love I remember when I was in my
formative years the Dodgers and the
Cincinnati Reds boy the Big Red Machine
oh yeah and everybody coming up through
their farm system every position was
strong right now it's it's tough to see
that now they're talking about the
Dodgers getting Stanton from Miami or
it's like it's it's kind of blown up if
the Dodgers get Stanton from my
would ruin their reputation of being the
pluckiest quarter billion dollar team
and all of them lucky is going with it
right you know that normally when you've
got 250 million in payroll you don't
have like that grit yes moxie
the Yankees are like 50 million dollar
payroll yeah but the Dodgers they're all
there they got Justin Turner with his
beard and he's right there the pluckiest
team like yeah Stanton in this town
would be ridiculous well he's from here
John Carter went to the same high school
my daughter went to is that right yeah I
did not know Notre Dame High School does
she have she loves baseball in fact she
was she was a catcher on in Little
League and she was like the only girl
there were like three girls in the
league itself in the entire league yeah
and she was catcher like she was like
the Tatum O'Neal of yeah she was she was
a tough little yeah and then yeah and if
she didn't like a call she she would do
it just like she wouldn't turn around
and look at the umpire she go oh come on
blue come on it's framed check it yeah
that's but that's a very Brian that's a
veteran move that a catcher never turns
around to show up the umpire yeah you
bark your complaint in the other
director sits little late like you know
the kids that literally are also
covering their mouths too because they
don't read it's amazing that I a yso
soccer you know yeah okay and a letter
that somebody sent out on an email to
all the parents saying we're on the eve
of playoffs and the the subject heading
read let's all pull together or
something like that and it devolved from
let's all pull together to I quit I hate
all you people you need to get better at
being parents and support the kids and
support the the coaches and support the
refs that wound up in the Daily Mail no
kidding there was a lot of pent-up anger
international so what I'm saying is it
you know at youth level it can get
particularly well I thought I coached my
daughter all the way through in
in basketball and in in baseball yeah
and in fact one and one year we had
jimmy kimmel son Kevin who and I coached
him and Kimmel would come out and kibitz
the whole time is funny guy what's what
sort of sports dad was Kimmel was he was
he he was good okay he was he stood back
but like you I too and these kids are
playing t-ball they're going how come my
kids not out there he's the better
player and it's like really they they
you know it's like in in in youth soccer
what's so fun to see and your kids went
through this is when they first start
out they hover around the ball like a
beehive oh yeah it's just the Flies it's
so cute you know and the positioning is
they can't understand that it's when
when when did you do you thought when
you were doing like malcolm in the
middle' you'd be yeah yeah and every day
and then go to practice and then go on
the weekends you do soccer and coach
soccer as well and yeah yeah and that
and the parents I think they're they're
letting out their pent-up anger and and
trying to live vicariously through what
maybe they didn't do yeah but
unnecessarily trying to dig in there and
have their kid be the star and you know
come on I know I feel funny that your
your daughter was a catcher that yeah
you don't usually hear that story no
that's pretty cool
Bryan Cranston here in the Rich Eisen
show we'll take a 60-second break come
back talk glass flag flying the play
that you referred to that you were doing
in London is Network which is one of my
favorite movies of all time you play
Howard Beale right who is one of the
greatest characters Peter Finch played
him as we passed away won an Oscar I
can't I want to pick your brain on that
today and then eventually as all our
conversations to they lead back to
Walter White that's alright that's
alright are you not just saying that no
you know I'm hopped up on a stair yeah I
got something I can help you with - yeah
I'll take care of you
we're back with Bryan Cranston in 60
seconds
all right welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show Bryan Cranston here for another
segment and another stay here on the
show always love having you here last
flag flying and select theaters right
now you Steve Carell Laurence Fishburne
Cicely Tyson yeah what a cast and the
director Richard Linklater and what he
has done in his career I mean what
attracted you to this this you know the
last flag flying you'll remember this to
being a movie buff remember the last
detail
good Nicholson Nicholson Randy Quaid
this was that was based on a novel so
was this it was actually written as a
sequel to the last detail this film this
film was supposed to be a sequel he
wrote at 15 years ago but Nicholson
didn't get around to it he was thinking
about it didn't get around to doing it
retired Randy Quaid went crazy in Canada
yes and Otis Otis I can't remember the
other actors name but he passed away so
there wasn't going to be a sequel to
that but Richard Linklater loved the the
McCue about it he loved the the the
world of these guys thirty years after
their military service are getting
together again for a specific purpose
and and oh his explore male friendship
how we bond why we bond how we we deal
with with grief and in and trouble in
our lives you know and it's it's really
beautiful but again I say it's it's one
of those those rare films that will
attract male and female audiences alike
and both will equally get something out
of its rich it's funny it's very
entertaining I'm very proud right
there's a journey involved obviously a
physical journey as well as one
emotionally as well so just knowing last
detail and then this film your character
would be the Nicholson would be the
Nicholson character because his take a
guy who sal is a guy who's just one of
those guys if I said Sal's coming over
you would grimace and grab your head Oh
God not today not today please I can't
deal with him he takes the air out of a
room
he's a consumer
of mass quantity he says yes to
everything drugs women drink you know
every food I want it all I'm gonna smoke
it I want to drink it I want to have sex
with it I would but he's also the first
one to say yes what do you need I'm your
friend I'm gonna help you are we getting
into a fight all right who we hit you
know he's that kind of guys like are you
crazy
he's a little crazy and he's also
self-medicating but that's his way of
coping with his own PTSD that he hasn't
dealt with in any other way and Vietnam
from the Vietnam War Laurence Fishburne
finds a way to deal with his PTSD
through God and and reimagining himself
and Steve Carell is his character is
depressed its kind of imploded him a bit
but throughout this journey the three of
us and our bonding we we expose that and
we deal with it and it opens up and it's
it's really a nice move well I'm such a
big fan of all three of yours so I'm
curious what was it like bonding with
these guys on the set is it the first
time that you worked with I had worked
with fish before on a movie called
contagion oh here's years earlier they
Soderbergh movie yeah yeah and we got on
great and I couldn't wait to work with
him again
and Carell I've known all over the years
but we've never worked together and when
I read the script not knowing which role
I was they were asking me to play I
thought it could be his role because his
is more serious and I thought because
I'm basically known for more serious
work he's basically known from a comedic
work and I thought oh it could be that
way but Richard Linklater said no no I
want you to play Sal and him to play doc
I mean how are you not I mean again
associated with comedy I guess Breaking
Bad kind of yeah kind of pivoted in that
risk it did but I mean it laid more of a
foundation from me and while speaking of
just the comedy work Curb Your
Enthusiasm here you showed up for one
episode
in this what is it like for you working
with Larry - god I love it he is he is a
lovely curmudgeon just a funny guy and
in every every actor going on that show
wants to be able to see if they can get
him to crack up if you can if you can
get him it's just a great feeling you
know but what he does in the show and he
just tells you he says okay in this
scene we need this piece of information
now you have to do that and I have to
get out this information and then
everything else is just ad-libbed we
just roll it's nothing is scripted you
just go with it I know what you mean
about the laughs we he was here a couple
weeks ago we now just we kept it and we
use it every now and then you got a form
right there Mike though twofold so so I
noticed something that when I was doing
Seinfeld
I didn't notice about Larry he uses his
jaw when he laughs oh my god that's
strange but he's a genius
I hope they do another curve man so do i
and and and 8g HBO has said you know
whenever you want to do it just let us
know all right
and speaking of doing work once again
better call Saul now okay we're getting
to the part we're getting there where
where it moves it's more we're moving
slow I'm movin like Tortuga we're moving
that slowly okay but we're getting to
the part where Walter White could show
up are we seeing Walter White any times
well I'll tell you this as an exclusive
on the Rich Eisen show nice putting
without the mug there it is there's the
exclusive what I can tell you yes is
that I have no no news to tell you
pulling your leg this whole time I just
don't know yeah
Vince Gilligan Peter Ghul who
that show I love them I owe them so much
I would do anything for them before they
finished the sentence I would be on a
plane to Albuquerque if they wanted me
to do something right so in doing that
what we would see him before maybe we
could see him before away in a way that
his cancer diagnosis we could see him
post cancer diagnosis right even though
again we didn't meet Saul until
afterwards just seeing you in the pre
Breaking Bad world it's conceivable
somewhere it's conceivable they're
operating out of Albuquerque New Mexico
and it's not that big of town and it's
spoiler alert though I mean it just
amazes me seeing in breaking band in
better call Saul the number of
characters whose demise eventually is
met because of your character it is
remarkable how each and every one of
them yeah eventually has to be undone I
unfortunately have that association if I
spend any amount of time with someone
they end up dying surprisingly so I
would suggest you get life insurance you
know you want to protect your family and
everything everything you do that okay
sorry
so and then network you're viewing this
on the London stage yeah correct you're
playing Howard Beale right now this is
one of my favorite movies of all time
because paddy Chayefsky wrote it
Siddalee Sidney Lumet direct that's
correct
predicted everything about news
television yeah
and entertainment he's you know way in
advance it was written in the in 1974
1975 and it was a satire on the news and
the packaging and the manipulation of
audiences and the propaganda force that
television is and the power of it and
now we see it's come to fruition when
when the news is actually slanted toward
an agenda of one way or the other and it
is also a show if you watch network news
now which is kind of difficult to watch
it's always a lead-in they'll talk about
frivolous things and then they'll talk
about stay tuned tonight we're gonna
have a great show the lineup on the
broadcast networks that night and we
take it a little further we have an
applause sign and you know it's the news
the network news is all about you you
know but Howard Beale the mad prophet of
the airwaves which we're seeing in so
many different ways regardless of where
your political bent is where it's a
monolithic personality at the forefront
telling you an opinion on the news
sometimes just railing on society's ills
and everybody falling in there yeah
we're that that was the character of
Howard be a lot that's exactly right out
of your window open open and stick your
head out and yell I'm mad as hell and
I'm not gonna take it anymore
is that what do you how do you do it I
do it very well how do you I'm sure like
preparing for the role to nail that that
line do you have do you have oh I just
what do you do you know I when I when I
first say it I want it to be a surprise
even to him okay he didn't know he was
this is what he was gonna say so he kind
of stumbles through it and then he he
recognizes the power of what he just
said and then he and then he kind of
encapsulates it and holds on to it and
presents it it's a dynamic play it
really is I'm having a great time we're
running through the end of March but the
show has already been sold out before we
even opened I would definitely put my
pounds down to do it oh well now or is
it coming to America I don't know I
don't know I mean I'm just focusing
right now on doing the play okay I never
do something as a stepping stone to
something else I just want to I do this
to tell this story if we do it well and
I have a great experience there maybe a
life after that but we'll find it well
for a certain endeavor in terms of I'm
mad as hell I'm not going to take it
anymore
I would like if you would indulge me for
you to say those lines as other
characters if you've
trade in your in your career oh yeah yes
I would
again just blame it on the steroid hey
yes that I've got going on right now so
would you try it I'm mad as hell I'm not
gonna take it anymore as season 1 Walter
White a break season 1
Walter was before he was Heisenberg
correct correct season 1 Walter White
would say I'm mad as hell I'm not gonna
take any more it's probably this way I'm
I'm mad as hell and I'm I'm I'm not
gonna take it anymore he's not sure I'm
sure he's right yeah ok so now let's get
to the Heisenberg who era how would how
would he say the the line of Howard
Beale I'm mad as hell and I'm not gonna
take it anymore that sounds fantastic
yeah that works he better tread lightly
right yeah yeah how about Tim Watley how
would want Lee say well I'm mad as hell
and forgive me a little SH nickel of it
Mike
I'm not gonna take it anymore I'm not
gonna take it I will not take it uh how
from Malcolm in the Middle
yeah I'm what was that go I'm scared as
hell what was it a mad as hell I'm mad
as hell I'm like oh I'm not gonna take
it anymore unless you want me to unless
you want me to then I'll take it I like
it
try that workshop that one when you go
back to London
work that a little bit work that into I
always love seeing you Brian thanks
thanks for stopping by thank you man
hope you feel better well do you have
any advice for me on my steroids not
advice I have you know some product ok
yeah yeah yeah you make it you'll still
have a bad back so he won't even care to
manage the Matt is the magical company
involved fantastic
Bryan Cranston check out last flag
flying in select theaters right now
Steve Carell Laurence Fishburne Cicely
Tyson and this man Bryan Cranston the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience